What if I told you that one of the
world's most dangerous
conflicts, a flashpoint that
has pushed nuclear powers to the brink,
all started with a receipt?
Sounds impossible, doesn't it?
But in 1846 the British Empire sold the
entirety of Kashmir, its
mountains, its rivers and
most importantly its people, to a local
ruler for 7.5 million rupees.
This is the story of that sale and how it
lit a fire that nearly
175 years later refuses
to go out.
So how exactly do you
sell an entire kingdom?
To understand that you have
to picture the world in 1846.
The Indian subcontinent was a chaotic
high-sticks chessboard.
The old Mughal Empire was gone.
In its place were ambitious local rulers
and the unstoppable
British East India Company.
In the northwest you had the powerful
Sikh Empire, a major
force in the Punjab region.
But after the death of its great leader,
Maharajadiranjit Singh, the
empire began to crack from the
inside and watching it all
were two global superpowers.
In the south the British East India
Company was quickly
shifting from a business to a
colonial empire.
And from the north the Russian Empire was
creeping south across Central Asia.
This shadowy contest for influence became
known as the Great Game.
For Britain controlling the mountains of
northern India was everything.
These territories were the buffer, the
great wall that would
keep Russia away from the
jewel in the crown of its empire, India.
The chaos in the Sikh Empire was the
opening Britain was waiting for.
After a series of clashes the first
Anglo-Sikh war broke out.
The British, with better discipline and
modern weapons, won a
decisive victory in 1846.
They defeated Sikhs were forced to pay a
crushing war indemnity.
But their treasury was empty.
So Britain made them an
offer they couldn't refuse.
Instead of cash they would take the land.
Specifically the vast, beautiful and
strategic Kashmir Valley.
Just like that Britain owned Kashmir.
But they didn't want to
actually rule it directly.
It was too remote and
too difficult to manage.
Their goal was simple.
Create a loyal buffer state.
They needed a buyer and
they knew exactly who to call.
Enter Gulab Singh, a clever and ambitious
Dogra Rajput
chieftain from Jammu, who had
technically been a
vessel of the Sikh Empire.
But during the war he played a masterful
game of diplomacy, staying
neutral and making himself
useful to the British.
His so-called neutrality was a calculated
gamble that paid off,
earning him Britain's
favour.
Just one week after acquiring Kashmir the
British sealed the deal with him.
On March 16, 1846 they
signed the Treaty of Amritsar.
The terms were brutally simple.
The British government made over forever
in independent
possession to Maharaja Gulab
Singh, all the mountainous
country it had just taken.
This land, including the Kashmir Valley,
would become the new
princely state of Jammu and
Kashmir.
And the price for this new kingdom?
7.5 million rupees.
Specifically the rupees of
the former Sikh Treasury.
To add a symbolic flourish of who was
really in charge, Gulab
Singh also had to present
the British with an annual tribute.
One horse, twelve priced shawl goats and
three pairs of luxurious Kashmiri shawls.
Let's not mince words here, this was not
a treaty between equals.
It was a transaction.
The British just sold a piece of land
they had just acquired and
its millions of inhabitants
as if it were just a piece of property.
The people of Kashmir, who were
overwhelmingly Muslim, were never asked.
They had zero say in their own fate.
Overnight they were sold to a new Hindu
ruler from a different
region, whose power would
be guaranteed by the British military.
One of the most beautiful and strategic
places on this earth was
treated like a cynical acid
flip in a brutal game of empire.
The deal was done, the receipt was signed
and the fuse was lit.
The creation of the state of Jammu and
Kashmir was a disaster waiting to happen.
It established an autocratic Dogra
dynasty to rule over a
population that had little
in common with its new masters.
The divide was immediate and stark, the
rulers were Hindu, while
the majority of the most
populous region, the
Kashmir Valley, was Muslim.
For the next century the Dogra regime's
rule was often oppressive.
For many Kashmiris it felt less like a
government and more like an occupation.
Crush in taxes were placed on the
majority Muslim
population, taxes on everything from
homes and fruit trees to
even the local gravedigger.
Muslim peasants were often pushed off
their land, effectively
becoming tenant farmers
on property their families once owned.
Forced unpaid labour,
known as bagar, was widespread.
The administration often favoured the
state's Hindu minority,
creating a system that enriched
the ruling class and left the majority of
people poor and without political power.
Any attempt at political
protest was met with force.
This century of discrimination created a
deep and lasting bitterness.
It wasn't just about economic hardship,
it was a profound sense of injustice.
The people of Kashmir felt that they had
been sold into servitude.
Their rights and identity ignored by both
the British and the Dogra rulers.
This anger lasted for decades, a pressure
cooker just waiting
for a moment of crisis.
That moment came in 1947 when the British
Empire, the very power
that created this artificial
state announced it was
leaving India for good.
The year 1947 brought the partition of
British India into two new
nations, the secular Hindu
majority state of India and
the Muslim state of Pakistan.
The 560 plus princely
states were given a choice.
Join India, join Pakistan or
theoretically become independent.
For Maharaja Hari Singh, Gulab Singh's
great grandson, this
was an impossible choice.
His state had a Muslim majority, which
suggested joining Pakistan.
But as a Hindu ruler he was afraid of
giving up his power.
Joining a democratic India was also a bad
option, as it meant
losing his absolute monarchy.
So Hari Singh stalled, dreaming of an
independent Kashmir.
But his kingdom was already on fire.
Decades of resentment had finally boiled
over, an uprising
against his rule erupted in the
Poonch region.
Seeing the chaos, Pakistan made its move.
In October 1947, thousands of Pashtun
tribesmen, supported by
the Pakistani state, invaded
Kashmir to seize it by force.
They advanced quickly,
closing in on the capital, Srinagar.
With his kingdom collapsing, a desperate
Hari Singh turned to
India for military help.
India agreed, but on
one critical condition.
Kashmir had to formally accede to India.
On October 26, 1947, Maharaja Hari Singh
signed the instrument of accession.
The very next day, Indian troops were
airlifted to Srinagar to
fight back the invaders.
Pakistan immediately contested the
accession, arguing it was
forced upon the Maharaja against
the will of the people.
The tribal invasion turned into the first
full-scale war
between India and Pakistan.
The explosion that was primed a century
earlier had finally happened.
The war wasn't the start of the Kashmir
conflict, it was the
inevitable violent result of a
business deal made in 1846.
The first Indo-Pakistani war ended in
1949 with a UN-brokered ceasefire.
The ceasefire line sliced right through
Jammu and Kashmir,
leaving roughly two-thirds under
Indian control and the
rest under Pakistani control.
This temporary line, later renamed the
Line of Control,
became the de facto border.
Today, it's a heavily militarized,
fiercely contested frontier
that has been the flashpoint
for two more major wars
and countless smaller fights.
At that time, India's leaders had
proposed that the
accession could be finalised by a
website, a popular vote for the people of
Kashmir to decide their own fate.
That vote never happened.
The reasons why are complex and fiercely
debated to this day, but the
result was that the temporary
division became permanent, cementing a
conflict that has defined
South Asian politics for
over 75 years.
The story of Kashmir is a stark reminder
of how a single
decision, made by a distant power
looking out for its own interests, can
create generations of tragedy.
If you found this story compelling,
please consider liking
this video and subscribing
for more deep dives into the history
behind today's headlines.
What happened in 1846 was
more than a real estate deal.
It was the sale of a people's future, the
wars, the insurgency,
the nuclear brinkmanship
and the immense human suffering that
define Kashmir today all
can be traced back to that
one cynical document,
the Treaty of Amritsar.
The British didn't just tell a kingdom,
they sold the future
piece of a subcontinent
and it's a price that's still
being paid in blood and tears.